seitdem ich mit 1625 er gefahren bin
will ich unbedingt gullys lernen das ist
fester bestandteil der motorrad kultur
man sieht das gefühl in jedem video und
es ist der kick flip des motorradfahrens
ist gehört einfach dazu
nachdem ich mit 16 kläglich daran
gescheitert bin mein motorrad mehrmals
zerstört habe und mich auch dabei
verletzt habe möchte ich das ganze jetzt
noch mal in angriff nehmen und in den
nächsten sieben tagen ein release
vielleicht mache ich das diesmal aber
nicht alleine sondern hole mir jemanden
dazu der wirklich ahnung hat nummer 1
ich bin jetzt gerade schon auf einem
etwas abgelegenen parkplatz in köln
unterwegs ist tatsächlich gar nicht so
einfach in köln was zu finden wo man so
ein bisschen mehr motorrad herum
probieren kann
ich bin aber nicht alleine ich weiß ja
gar nicht wie ich das machen soll
habe mir deswegen experten dazu geholt
mit einem wunderschönen motorrad
derjenige weiß aber auch wie er mit dem
motorrad umzugehen hat und zwar bin ich
mit city unterwegs
ihr werdet den wahrscheinlich schon
kennen wenn ihr euch in der schule
endlich
[Musik]
basics machen wo wir noch nicht so
vielleicht total gehen nicht so
attraktiv und dann bin ich mir auch
sicher dass das schiefgeht klar man
sollte so motorradfahren schon sehr
verinnerlicht haben sage nicht nur wenn
es schon an die erste mobiles gerät und
sonst halt der key to success die
hinterradbremse also dass so das
werkzeug was ich quasi immer wieder
helfen kann egal wie streng nach hinten
kippt oder so die hinterradbremse
verinnerlicht dann kommt aber ja das ist
ein langer weg
ja mal sehen ob das in sieben tagen
klappt ich glaube dass schon ziemlich
zeit als schon sehr sehr perfektionieren
tut man das natürlich über über
jahrelange erfahrungen viel fahren
einfach aber vielleicht klappt das ganze
heere sowie es hat mir dann erst mal
gezeigt wie es aussehen könnte um zwar
nicht nur auf seinem motorrad mit dem er
extrem vertraut ist sondern auch direkt
auf meinem der kann release so gut so
sicher das ist kein problem für ihn war
ohne einmal auf einem motorrad gesessen
zu haben
die karte sofort in den juli zu ziehen
und die aufzuhalten sehr beeindruckend
aber gleichzeitig auch sehr hilfreich
weil movies mir dadurch sagen konnte in
welchem gang ich am besten mit meinem
motorrad über und allgemeinen die ich
mit dem motorrad umzugehen
dadurch dass wir noch die an das ist
ziemlich kurz übersetzten und ziemlich
aggressiv hungers wenn du es irgendwann
mal was wirst du nicht mehr so machen
aber für den anfang würde ich
tatsächlich empfehlen dritter oder
vierter gang ok dass wir sehr unter
trick ist und du nicht so schnell an den
punkt kommt wo du überlebst
unkontrollierbar wird ja dadurch dass
die drehzahl so tief ist hast du relativ
wenig leistung und du holst dir mit
kupplung hoch oder ich würde die mit
kupplung hoch okay wenn die maschine
einmal oben ist und sie dann nochmal gas
gibst du steigt dem nicht extrem nach
oben
okay weil du halt unterdrückt ist dann
hat würde ich wirklich mal probieren
dritter vielleicht sogar vier tagen ein
bisschen mehr kupplung bisschen
ausprobieren was du lieber ist ganz kurz
bevor es weitergeht das projekt hat mir
wirklich eine menge spaß gemacht und war
auch sehr aufwendig lass mir gerne ein
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren damit die keines der
folgenden videos verpasst und bleibt bis
zum ende dran am ende kommt ein sehr
sehr nice edit von dem relief als sich
ihnen nach sieben tagen geschafft haben
sollte
viel spaß ich bin dann erst mal im kreis
auf und ab gefahren und habe die
hinterradbremse benutzt das hört sich
sehr basic an ist aber sehr wichtig das
genauso zu verinnerlichen weil das eben
die notbremse oder die
im juli ist wenn man nur die kupplung
zieht geht es nach hinten in die falsche
richtung wenn man die hintere bremse
drückt geht es nach vorne wieder in die
richtige richtung da das relativ schnell
funktioniert hat ich habe die bremse ja
auch vorher schon mal benutzt habe ich
mich dann langsam an den ball heran
getastet der eigentlich vom prinzip her
gar nicht so schwer ist man zieht die
kupplung gibt ein bisschen gas lässt die
kupplung fliegen dann sollte das
motorrad forschung hochgehen wenn es
dann einmal oben ist ist es ein spiel
aus gas und hinterradbremse mit dem man
versucht das motorrad eben oben zu
halten man drückt die bremse es geht
vorne runter man gibt gas das motorrad
kommt wieder hoch hört sich einfacher an
als es ist es ist halt eine
koordinationsaufgaben aus beiden händen
und dem rechten bein wenn man das nicht
gemacht hat dann ist es tatsächlich
wirklich schwierig und man muss dafür
langsam ein gefühl entwickeln damit man
da kein risiko eingeht nach einer stunde
liegt das aber auch schon ziemlich gut
ich konnte das motorrad eigentlich jedes
mal vorne hochheben zwar nicht halten
aber das sollte dann eine aufgabe für
die nächsten tage werden
ich bin fest davon ausgegangen dass die
session für heute hier gelaufen wer aber
die lieben kollegen sind eins
vorbeigefahren naja aber wir sind hier
wirklich auf einem parkplatz hier steht
kein einziges auto also co wenn ich
ihren city dann circles gedreht hat und
ich weiter kläglich versucht habe das
motorrad vor noch zu bekommen aber dann
aber besuch von herrn bekommen das soll
es für heute gewesen sein die messe köln
hat uns gebeten hier mitzufahren
die motorräder sind jetzt auch nicht
besonders leise das nehmen wir so hin
brauchen dann für die nächsten tage
wahrscheinlich einen anderen spot sehr
sehr erfolgreicher erster tag gewesen
gut gefühl dafür bekommen wir sind noch
lange nicht am ziel
ich bekomme das motorrad aber zumindest
schon mal hoch mal schauen was die
nächsten tage so bringen schon mal
vielen dank
das war ein absoluter traum ich werde
nochmal auf deinen rat zurückkommen aber
für den ersten tag an tag 2 hat das
mikrofon rein gesagt deswegen glaube ich
jetzt einfach darüber ich habe mein
sport gefunden der nur 50 meter vom
alten entfernt war aber deutlich mehr
platz hatte wo ich niemanden gestört
habe sollte ich meinen das wird mir zum
ende des videos noch mal zum verhängnis
aber auf jeden fall konnte ich da für
die nächsten tage lang einfach
trainieren bin jetzt vielleicht fünfmal
oder so hin und her gefahren
jetzt fühlt sich so viel besser ich
soviel sicher ich trau mich suchen
mehr am gas so ein bisschen zu spielen
und kontrollieren aber nicht
stimmungsmäßig sondern immer schön
langsam absoluter augsburger heute
werden wir richtig fortschritte machen
ob wir das gesehen mit meinen job so gut
hat sich das noch nie in meinem leben
angefühlt so lang habe ich noch nie in
meinem leben gemacht kraft kraft kraft
trat hat nur damit sie versteht warum
ich nicht so freue und damit den ich
denke dass es komplett übertrieben wer
in den letzten jahren wollte ich habe
ich wirklich das verlangen den willi
vernünftig zu lernen und ich habe es
einfach nicht hinbekommen dass jetzt
innerhalb von so kurzer zeit innerhalb
von ein paar tagen so stabil
hinzubekommen war wirklich sehr sehr
nice für mich und ich freue mich auf den
sommer und alles was da motorrad mäßig
noch kommen an tag 3 war dann der
absolute durchbruch es hat super
funktioniert ich war extrem zufrieden
und hat aber auch gemerkt wie ich super
unvorsichtig geworden bin weil ich mir
meiner situation so sicher war das super
gefährlich bei solchen sachen hat euer
körper und eure gesundheit absolute
priorität aber natürlich ist nicht nur
die sicherheit ihres körpers sehr
wichtig wofür ich diese schon geholt
habt sondern auch die fragt euch warum
ich das gemacht habe naja es ist mir
hülle von renault zielt die sind
freundlicher unterstützung dieses videos
die höhlen gibt es in super vielen
verschiedenen farben schutz neuer handy
super krass und das werden wir jetzt mal
auf die probe stellen grundsätzlich gibt
zu sagen dass sie so ziemlich alles
machen was euer handy sicherer macht und
davor schützt kaputt zu gehen nicht nur
höhen sondern auch folien für die
rückseite folien für vorne oder
protektoren für die kamera sogar für
knöpfe sogar für knöpfe ich habe bei
meinem handy die knöpfe die schwarz
waren durch blaue ausgetauscht wenn wir
es besser gefallen hat nicht nur das es
zu wechseln sondern auch die rückseite
in der hülle könnt ihr wechseln so napp
lenkrad beispielsweise call up mit denen
die ich sehr sehr nice finde ansonsten
nasa league of legends naruto da kommt
auf jeden fall jeder auf seine kosten
gehabt hat schon gesehen dass das handy
mit der hülle so ziemlich alles aushält
was im alltag passieren kann aber was
ist also ein bisschen extremer wie
beispielsweise habe ich gerade eben auf
den weg
hierhin mein hemd aus versehen sie
liegen lassen und jetzt werden wir
schauen ob das auch aushält wenn ich im
juli über dieses handy mit der hütte
über habe jetzt geht es dem guten dinge
an den kragen
warum wir für ein unterschied dass die
nicht an den fragen gibt ja irgendwie
das gefühl dass ein bisschen unfair
attest
erst erwischte moment der wahrheit von
hier sieht es ganz gut aus ist alles
bestens glaube ich normal läuft noch
zimmer die schutzfolie ab
wir werden nie drüber gefahren cookies
kannst du auf ebay jetzt als neuwertig
verkaufen komplett verrückt check den
ersten linken der video beschreibung aus
da kommen wir zur ein schild könnte die
verschiedenen kollaborationen abchecken
und euch 15 prozent für die nächsten
zwei wochen sichern ich bin sehr
glücklich dass sie mich um diese
projekte unterstützen und jetzt gehts
weiter mit video und sagt hier und 5
habe ich dann angefangen das motorrad
wirklich kontrollieren zu lernen also
ich habe einen merklichen unterschied
gehabt ich glaube das sieht man sogar
wenn man von außen mich einfach beim
ueli betrachtet ich bin viel ruhiger ich
kontrolliere das motorrad mit meinen
beinen also quasi in welche richtung das
motorrad kippen soll
ich kann mit der hinterradbremse
arbeiten ich kann besser mit dem gas
arbeiten das waren wirklich die
absoluten durchbruch tage ich habe heute
max dabei damit er endlich mal
vernünftige aufnahmen von mir beim
machen kann ist so ein bisschen
bestandsaufnahme wie viel jetzt wirklich
hängen geblieben ist die letzten zwei
tage war super schlechtes wetter und ich
konnte nicht fahren
jetzt geht es endlich weiter all in all
muss ich sagen es fühlt sich ein
bisschen unsicher an dass jetzt zwei
tage nicht gemacht haben wir starten
haben einfach und gucken was davon
hängen geblieben ist
dr
stärke direkt dass es unsicher bin also
ich fand das schon sehr cool
ja das sieht vielleicht cool aus aber
ich fühle mich ein bisschen um sich ja
ja und dann hast du dich langsam an ich
doch noch bei sowas sollte nichts
überstürzen er genau bescheid erst mal
ein bisschen weiter und dann machen wir
gleich noch eine richtige bestanden
nach 23 versuchen war ich auch so die
angst los dass ich alles verlernt hätte
also es ist ja immer noch ein klarer
unterschied zum ersten tag zu den ersten
versuchen
ich habe scheinbar die basics wirklich
verstanden wie ich das motorrad hoch
bekomme auf jeden fall liegt das jetzt
genau da halte ohne schneller werden zu
müssen ohne mehr gas geben zu müssen
das ist jetzt die finale aufgabe für den
nächsten tag und dass es auch eigentlich
das was es wirklich zu lernen gilt aber
wie funktioniert das so viel besser
recht ja weil die halt viel weniger ja
er hat dieses viel ruhiger
kraft war aber die waren schon die
wahren saftig ja wie man sagt ja und man
wird halt auch schnell genau und das
darf eigentlich halt nicht passieren ja
weil man wild möglichst langsam keller
aber theoretisch kannst du ja so dein
verhalten am gas so inter unter schonung
bedingungen im dritten üben und dann
runter gehen ganz genau
wer er ist ja ich habe das gefühl wenn
es jetzt weiter machen würde würde ich
mir wehtun oder soja das lieber aufhören
und mit ein bisschen ruhe in den
nächsten tagen weiter machen und ihr
immer aufhören wir uns am schlechtesten
ist die regierung hat mittlerweile fühle
ich mich deutlich sicherer
ich habe jetzt das gefühl dass es quasi
nur noch um perfektion geht und dass
jetzt einfach wirklich eine reine
übungssache ist das immer mal wieder zu
machen
ich habe das in den letzten tagen wenn
ich es nicht geschafft habe hier auf den
platz zu kommen natürlich nicht auf der
straße gemacht und hatte dabei auch
nicht schon ein deutlich besseres gefühl
wer in der stadt absolut
verantwortungslos und solltet ihr auf
gar keinen fall machen deswegen sind
auch nicht gemacht
wir sind jetzt wieder hier und jetzt
wirklich weiter
schau mich halt jetzt einmal mit richtig
gas hoch zu kommen um dann halt mit
wenig gas oben zu bleiben ist nicht mehr
so dass ich mit wenig gas hoch her und
probiere mit viel gas oben zu bleiben
sondern ich lerne viel besser mit dem
gas und allgemein mit den ganzen
komponente der bremse und so umzugehen
fühlt sich an als hätte es nie was
anderes gemacht wirklich bin zwar auch
deutlich unruhiger und fangen jetzt an
weil ich denke ich bin sicher und macht
ihr so ne schlag den lenker ein und
geben also ein bisschen gas spiel so
damit aber es ist viel mehr weil ich
mich sicher fühle und mich jetzt
ausprobieren in verschiedene richtungen
japan tag eins nicht mal die
koordination zwischen kupplung und gas
vernünftig hinbekommen antrag sechs habe
ich mein training live stream das bleibt
den leuten hier auf youtube vorenthalten
ihr müsst auch typisch dabei sein damit
ihr das sehen könnt wenn ihr also das
nächste mal ein sneak peek zu dem
projekt haben wollt dann checke den link
in der video beschreibung schaut der
krieg vorbei wir machen sehr nasse
sachen ich habe am ende des streams dann
leider ein paar probleme bekommen wurde
von dem platz runtergeschmissen und
hatte dann auch keine
trainingsmöglichkeit nennen können ich
musste da ein bisschen umstrukturieren
an tag 7 habe ich mich dafür entschieden
nicht mehr zu trainieren sondern einfach
ein großes finale schön gefilmtes video
zu machen das kommt jetzt ich wünsche
euch viel spaß das war in sieben tagen
william
[Musik]
war
ja mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]